- I was invited by YouTube
to interview some politicians
and business leaders
who were attending the APEC
Summit in San Francisco,
and I showed up with a pile
of exams that I gave them
as a way to hear their
thoughts on education.
So here's what they had to say.
I actually have here this
year's JEE exam from India.
- Oh my God. Jesus.
- If I could give that
to you just for a second.
Don't worry, I won't ask
you to solve any problems.
- Seriously?
- Well, speaking of Australian education,
I have here just for a little bit of fun
the latest New South Wales economics exam,
the HSC, Higher School.
So I wanted to just hand it to you.
- Okay.
- As an example of the kind of things
that stress students out
in the US at the moment.
And just see if it brought
up any, I guess, emotions
of what it was like to sit an exam
or it brings back any stress in any way
or any other thoughts and
see if it jogs any memories
of your time at school.
- It does.
- Is this the IIT Joint Entrance Exam or?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Okay.
So I took a bunch of exams
to graduate from high school,
but these types of questions
do bring back a lot of memory.
- It is stressful to
look at these problems,
but I do think it goes back
to taking a deep breath
and what are the tools that
I can use to find the answer?
- I've sat a few of these over the years.
I did high school economics.
The textbooks in the Queensland
Education system at the time
were written by Brown.
And you know,
how we managed to navigate
the global financial crisis
without going into recession.
I put that down to a Queensland
high school education
using Browns, the textbooks
on macro and micro.
But these are fairly standard questions.
No, they don't excite anxiety in me
of any particular order of magnitude,
but I think normally in
preparing for anything,
there's going to be a level of anxiety
in making sure you've done your homework.
- It's amazing that you found that though.
- It's a very difficult one. I'd say that.
Yeah, very challenging.
I wouldn't pass this without
doing a lot more study myself,
but exams like this one,
they have a lot of questions
and it's very high
stakes, very competitive.
Often math exams are testing memorization
or things that perhaps don't seem
like they would ever be practical.
Do you think, if you
can remember back to any
of the math exams you took,
did those prepare you well
for your job now or for the real world?
- What I can tell you
from my own experience,
and it's interesting, I
had my own experience.
Obviously, my wife and I talk
about our own high school
and college experiences,
and then we see it in our children.
It's very different
and I don't think it's
actually necessarily
just a pure difference
of educational systems.
I also think the generation,
the decades make a difference too
in terms of approach to it.
And I would say that there
is something to be said
for the ideas that come
from actually having more of that sort
of blank canvas approach
as opposed to like,
here's like the methodology
that you have to go through.
Not having that time pressure also.
And so I think I would say
that it's probably a balance,
but I see the value in sort
of that more open-ended approach.
- I think balance is what we're doing.
We're walking the line
between hindering students
and crushing their soul
with exams like this
and actually helping
them learn effectively.
- Right, actually getting the substance
is important as well.
- Memorizing, remembering,
that aspect helps me really well right now
as a blind diplomat, right?
I have to remember a lot in my mind
when I'm entering into giving a speech
or a talk or dialogue.
That thinking in math actually
has translated into my work.
- Education for me has been
a preparation for life.
There's very little that I've studied,
I should say, in Chinese language
and Chinese history that I don't use
on an almost daily basis
because of where China
is in the world today.
Like this morning, I
was doing an interview
about Xi Jinping's summit
with President Biden.
Look, asked my staff
to find me the Chinese
readout of the meeting.
We couldn't find it quickly,
so I was reading the Chinese text
and to see whether certain
word usages had changed
or not from previous Chinese statements.
That's just one example of the work I do
where you draw directly on
what I learned back then.
- Have you noticed a difference
in how different countries
treat education maybe?
- Well, I've spent actually
most of my adult life in Asia.
My kids were with me.
So they lived and went to school in China
and then South Africa and Singapore
before we returned to the
US about four years ago.
So I have seen sort of up close
how education differs in
some of those countries.
One thing that is particularly
true in parts of Asia
that I think is really wonderful
is that the teaching profession
is really revered and respected.
The position of being
a teacher is something
that people really aspire to.
I wish that we would do more
in the United States also
to really lift up our
teachers in that way.
- Yeah, I really agree with that.
I think the way we treat
teachers means a lot
and says a lot about what
we value as a society
and yeah, I've even covered
some exams from India
and China before,
and even the people, the students
who top those exams in the
country become mini celebrities
for a while there, you know?
This person has got the highest score.
Everyone knows their name.
So I think that that's a culture
that I think can help foster learning
and foster people wanting to do well.
So you've studied in
more than just Australia.
You went on to Oxford and elsewhere
and you've been all around
the world through your jobs,
but have you seen a difference
in how perhaps different
countries treat education?
- Well, demonstrably so.
Each of them has their
own culture of learning,
but I think there is certainly a tradition
of academic rigor about a
college-level education here.
There is a greater emphasis
on the quantitative,
even within the social
sciences than you see
in the Anglo-Australian universities.
- It's my understanding that you did a bit
of your education in the
US and a bit in India.
So I'd love to ask you,
how did those educational
experiences differ?
Did you find that those two countries
treated education differently?
- That's a really interesting question.
Probably one of the most
interesting questions
I've ever gotten.
It was a bit of a shock for me moving
from Michigan to India.
Part of this probably had
to do with my interest,
but it was very science and math focused.
That's what my interests
also happened to be.
So let me just put it this way.
By the time I got done
with high school in India,
I felt very, very prepared for college.
I came out actually right here to Stanford
for college, and I was a
very well prepared freshman,
let's put it that way.
The Indian system's pretty intense.
I had a conversation with a
friend of mine the other day
and we were just talking about
all the textbooks that we had
to use back in the day.
And so you said you're physics, right?
So like Resnick and Halliday,
like the pages of those books
are still seared in my
brain from my time in India.
- All right, as a last question
before I let you go,
do you have any advice
for students perhaps taking
their exams at the moment
on how to handle stress and
what they're going through?
- For me, one thing was
confidence is a big part of it,
but also understanding that school
might be the most
important thing right now,
but later on in life,
every single experience
you have that you're taking
through exams in schools will
be an amazing learned lesson
for later on in life.
So things turn out for the best
and always try to choose
a path, educational path
that's aligned to your interests
and your value and your potential.
That will make a huge difference.
- Well, thank you very
much for talking with me.
- Yeah, I enjoyed the conversation.
- Happy to do it.
- And I heard a rumor that
you wanted to touch my hair.
- Oh my God, yes.
- So I'll pass it over to you.
- Oh my God, you passed it over to me.
- Oh wow, it's so long
- So it's just below my knees. Yeah.
Thank you for watching
and thank you to my Patreon supporters.
A special shout out
to today's Patron Cats of
the Day, Grape and Ditto.
(lively music)